if you were the main protagonist of one
piece what are the three best devil
fruits you needed to change the world
and i mean from start to finish not only
defeating blackbeard and the world
government but turning the world into a
better place for everyone this is how
you do it
so what is the most powerful devil fruit
there is that's a question that has been
asked by a lot of people and the answer
usually is some variation of a top 10
list that contains pretty much the same
fruits every single time with an
unexpected and quite unquote
unconventional fruit thrown in there for
some novelty and honestly i'm a bit
tired of that format and yes you clicked
on my thumbnail because it's a pretty
damn good one if i dare say so but you
probably are dreading the same
repetitive video as well so for the sake
of all our sanities instead of looking
at individual fruits and giving my
opinion of how much boom boom each of
these does i want to look at devil
fruits from a perspective i found leaks
more fascinating to think about anyway
what are the best devil fruits when they
have the chance to be used together in a
strategic way to achieve a greater goal
and i'm not only talking about battle
here i think very different devil fruits
become incredibly powerful depending on
the context you want to use them
and so i thought to myself how could i
change the world faster than luffy what
exactly would i need to do so i sat down
with a pen and paper had a big big cup
of coffee and started brainstorming and
in the end i managed to work out four
foolproof steps in which the right
combination of devil fruits will be an
absolute game changer and to make it
more interesting since devil fruits are
really hard to come by i will limit
myself to three devil fruits per step
okay so i want you to close your eyes
for a second here i want you to imagine
that you are now the protagonist of one
piece you have all the knowledge about
this world that you currently have and
it's your destiny to save this world and
delete it into a better future you and a
handful of chosen nakama so what do you
have to do the goal obviously will be to
take down the world government defeat
blackbeard and create a peaceful and
prosperous world
well first of all there's the issue that
we need to get our hands on the devil
fruits that we actually want and the
poneglyphs on top to find love tale and
so the first of our five categories
therefore will be a science slash
information gathering squads and the
best devil fruit to start out with here
i think is violas giro giro no me that
allows the user to see through
everything with this you can look
anywhere for anything you want check if
there's a devil fruit on board of that
ship over there no problem check if
there is a treasure at the bottom of the
sea here no problem or even check if
there's a poneglyph around somewhere you
could also use it to scout to spy and
even avoid traps of any sort oh and did
i mention that it can actually
read minds
with this fruit you can locate all
resources you will need on this journey
money devil fruits information
anything the only problem is that you
might not be able to do much about it
even if you've found a lot of things so
this is where the other two fruits come
in the openomi quite well named if i
dare say so as well as montour's
bukubukunomi that devil fruit in
particular not only comes with its own
little pocket dimension how useful is
that but you can also store anything and
everything inside books including living
things
[Music]
so all the treasure and resources you
could pick up could be effortlessly
stored inside books without having ever
to worry about running out of space plus
you can even use this ability to build a
communication network
and all this is then perfected by the
openomi's room ability that allows you
to simply switch out the very item you
want and directly store it in a book so
you could simply scout a devil fruit in
a chest of a marine ship in the harbor
and simply use the opiopinomi to
transport it right onto your ship
without the marines ever suspecting
anything from another ship far far away
pretty neat i gotta say so this first
step is our ultimate base on which we
can now build on you have free access to
all information and resources you could
ever want the next thing we need is the
ability to move freely wherever we go
topple pirate crews and corrupt
governments and get rid of antagonists
that are too strong for us to face yet
and so for this political slash
infiltration team so our one piece cia
of sorts we can first of all reuse the
opi me not only can we get in and out
very quickly if we want to but in case
you've forgotten this devil fruit has
also the ability to switch personalities
[Applause]
so you can easily just restrict yourself
or one of your crew members then change
that personality with someone of your
enemy's side with this you could
infiltrate easily or if you wanted to go
really dark manipulate people to get to
their devil fruits if you know what i
mean
and as if this wasn't powerful enough
yet i would add sugar's hobby hobby
fruit as well as absalon tsuki tsuki
nomi to the mix as well
[Music]
with that you can make a number of
people invisible to get to places unseen
or simply spy and observe and with
suga's fruit you know in a way it's the
spookiest ability in all of one piece i
feel you could literally be invisible or
switch body with king and then simply
touch kaido
and suddenly no one remembers that there
ever was a yonko named kaido
[Music]
mina
now would have to obey your every order
really dark and spooky thought but
definitely effective so now we actually
have the means to get close to pretty
much anyone topple countries and erase
enemies from memory even still this
might not be enough yet while in theory
you could try and take out eem or
blackbeard that way we have to assume
that these groups are powerful enough
themselves to deal with such a sneak
attack so now that you can gather all
the resources you need might as well go
to lovetale and learn the true history
and oh boy you can't share what was on
love's tale but now you're really pumped
to change the world and you know what
that means we're now going for the big
guns by the way if by any chance you're
enjoying this let me know if you'd like
to see a version where i only get to use
one fruit in total at the start and
everything is just as in the story it
might actually be a lot of fun to figure
out as well so i'd be thrilled if you'd
consider subscribing to see that step
three build an army okay so now we're
getting to the boom boom party
and i personally think that that's a lot
more enjoyable to think about now
instead of just going what can make the
most damage in general you know what i
mean one thing we should do now of
course is start building an army sadly
you're not luffy and so you don't have
this special ability to bring everyone
to your side so instead we have to make
do with what we got here by liberating
countries we can get their soldiers to
join us i guess and by turning other
pirate captains into toys we can then
stroll by casually and recruit their men
to our cause and maybe even share some
crucial information with the
revolutionaries to have them in as well
and then just cause some internal
conflict within the marines as well just
in case you know to make sure
[Music]
nice that's looking pretty good now so
now that you have your own army the
first thing we want of course is a big
boom boom machine and that right now to
me can be none other than kaido's
even if it isn't an actual ancient
weapon it might as well be one i mean
come on
with this you can deal a lot of wide
area damage create storms make things
float and accept to people with strong
conquerors hockey you're practically
invincible i think that's a pretty great
choice for some decent dps and compared
to the guru guru nominee you don't risk
dealing a lot of collateral damage to
have your men as well looking back at
marine forge that was a really wild ride
with whitebeard's power there
next instead of just going for more
firepower here i would balance the
dragon with martia's heel heel fruit
which is able to affect a large number
of people and so is essential to staying
a strong and prepared force even during
battle as well as bartolomeo's body body
now that may sound like a bit of an odd
choice but not only can you use it to
block enemies attacks of any sort but
you can even shield your own army at the
beginning while launching a wide area
attack at the same time it can be used
to make a path for your troops up a wall
or a mountain or i don't know even
shield someone and have them walk in the
middle of the enemy and of course some
of the previous devil fruits we've
already gathered will be just as useful
here for example you can use the opi
opinomi to transport troops quickly or
destroy enemy ships with this absolutely
ridiculous force it should be easy to
defeat even the likes of blackbeard
akainu and emu using a mix of military
and political strategy to bring down the
system that has plagued the one-piece
world for centuries now however it will
also be your responsibility to make sure
that the world actually does become a
better place and doesn't sink into more
chaos you already have the means to
secure political power for now and keep
others trying to take advantage of the
situation at bay and so i think the best
way to unite the people of the world is
to actually have a land mass where
people can live together in peace after
all don't forget the one piece world is
99 water now in case you're wondering
new land masses are often created by
volcanic eruptions underwater like this
new island that was formed just a few
years ago on the canaries which is a
hell of a spectacular and impressive
process i think and luckily there is a
devil fruit out there that is just
perfect for this
with the help of akainu's magu magunomi
you could create landmasses throughout
the one-piece world connect islands and
widening existing landmasses yes the
poor person with that fruit would have
to work for quite a while but who knows
maybe akainu himself might be the right
candidate to deal with his anger issues
that way
once the magma has solidified aided by
storms created by our useful little
dragon an incredibly powerful fruit to
have will be pikas ishi ishinomi with
that fruit instead of wasting it by
getting small balls abusing steroids you
could actually shape entire islands into
cities with walls buildings and
infrastructure for people to use
heck now that i think about it you could
even change the geography in such a way
to create the perfect climatic
conditions for agriculture forming huge
terraces with rivers flowing from the
mountains you could shield cities from
floods by raising the ground and create
the optimal conditions for a new country
to flourish
honestly this is such an overpowered and
youthful fruit pika and sugar really
made the worst out of their abilities
[Music]
so now that we have free housing free
infrastructure free healthcare and can
shape our terrain whatever way we want
the last problem we face here is that
everything is still very well no pun
intended but
rocky yes volcanic rounds are very
fertile but it would take forever to get
vegetation everywhere and so the third
fruit you should use to solve that
problem is none others than stroy sense
do you know what it is
[Music]
now this may sound weird at first but
really think about it this fruit is as
ridiculously opie in terms of
civilization building as it gets you can
take infinite stone that we've made with
the magumagunomi from water and turn it
into actual nutritious food for all the
people how crazy is that but even better
than that you could turn large chunks of
rock into vegetables and grains and all
you have to do is take the seeds of that
and plant them all over the place to not
only create vegetation but vegetation
that can be turned into food ladies and
gentlemen this is the fruit to start a
flourishing economy and honestly what
better way to have people forget their
prejudices against fishman and the other
races if there is enough space enough
food and enough wealth for everyone boom
one piece solved in four easy steps with
less than a dozen devil fruits as you
can tell i'm in a bit of a devil fruit
frenzy at the moment and if you are too
and want to know why shanks actually
might have stolen the gomu gomu no me i
strongly recommend you watch that video
next
there it is this is it